the president is finishing his first
year in office and two influential
political reporters say little has
changed about the way he's perceived in
his job Mike Allen writes with Jim
VandeHei this morning that the president
quote started 2017 with about 40% of the
country with him and he ends 2017 with
about 40%
he started haunted by Russian
interference in his election when in he
ends 2017 pretty much the same way
they're calling it the rerun presidency
Mike Allen is co-founder and executive
editor of Axios a digital news site he
launched Axios this year with VandeHei
who helped create Politico ten years ago
Mike good morning well thank you I
thought I was here for the nine-minute
ad you can stick around in this whole
idea of the rerun presidency you say
Mike that there are only two people who
can change Trump Trump and Muller how do
you mean well that's right and one thing
that they told me early on in the
campaign somebody said to me that there
are all these stories Oh like probably
different after he's elected and
different after he's inaugurated
somebody said if you want to know and
you guys have known that guy if you want
to know one guy who's not changing it's
a 70 year old billionaire with his name
on the building and that's Trump he's
not changing and the one person you're
right that could totally disrupt their
ego system ecosystem and ego system is
Robert Muller that it's just handling
that investigation do you think so he's
taking the don't worry be happy'
approach that what we see again and
again is the adviser coddling the
president right like yesterday your
coverage of the national security
strategy the book is very serious the
speech was very trumpian they said here
mr. president like you'll enjoy this
speech so when Muller they're telling
him
it'll be fine and remember it was gonna
be over Thanksgiving then it was gonna
be over Christmas now it's to be over at
New Year's now the Washington Post
reporting Moeller folks expect to go a
year and that's very consistent with our
reporting which is whatever you think
Muller's up to there's more there's
always more and we saw that this weekend
when we found out that he has tens of
thousands of emails from the political
leadership and
national security team at the campaign
imagine what he can do one of the
mailboxes by itself 7,000 emails I'm
that's what a prosecutor can what's that
gonna do to his ability to govern in the
next year do you think like well that's
what they've tried to do is just pretend
that it's not there
President Clinton you guys will remember
was pretty good at Carbon
compartmentalizing and he was able to
put his investigation aside whatever
President Trump is good at
compartmentalizing ain't it it's always
on his mind he'd liked to talk about it
you see him out he never attacked
smaller personally though you are right
that is that is a great point that he
always goes after the investigation but
this is a man who's not known for
patience but they've told him just
cooperate with Maura give him documents
let him have the interviews and
eventually this will wind up in a good
place and Gale a staff member pointed
out to me that there's one person that
the president always wants to punch
anybody who's about to punch him or
might there's one person who does not
have a nickname that's an adversary the
president and that's more like we have
not heard it's a molar big name yeah and
why do you think that is they're trying
to not antagonize him the president
might do well to add that strategy to
Capitol Hill maybe not antagonize some
Republican senators but at least he's
doing it with this prosecutor so what
would happen when Muller releases his
report what happens after a special
counsel it leads to either charges or a
congressional investigation what's that
next step Ilyn or of course we have no
idea where he's headed but what we do
know from reading the indictments from
looking at what he does publicly we know
that he is willing to go very broad to
go after personal finances the White
House talking point keeps being oh he
has a very narrow mandate he's no like
the opposite is true first of all he has
very broad man look at the press release
it says Russia and anything related you
well know from your own coverage what
prosecutor can do with anything related
so he's gonna pull every threat on the
sweater we see that from the indictments
and the the police that we've seen so
far so we don't know where he's going
but this is this we talked about the
inside game of the
Trump lawyers trying to cooperate the
outside game which we've seen covered
here is all these Republicans saying oh
like the investigation is tainted or the
investigation is political just raise
questions so that President Trump can go
to his people you and I were talking
about this in the green room that that
his base is thin when he comes to 20/20
he's gonna have a math problem
he barely won he hasn't added to it he
has to keep those people and so that's
why the effort to undermine Muller is so
crucial to his long-term survival well
Mike Allen of axia is always good to
have you your Axios am your top ten I
not only read it online I then print it
out for myself so you Rock part of a
good breakfast this morning so thank you
hope you have something to discuss in
2018